[Music]
let me welcome you to this seventh
installation and this quarterly series
that's hosted by the Frank Weinberg
library philosophers in the midst of
history each year we look at for
philosophers one from ancient period one
medieval one early modern and then one
late modern so this is the modern time
and we're going to look at one of the
fathers of not just modernity itself but
modern political philosophy Thomas
Hobbes
who is quite an extraordinary guy
I'm Greg Sadler I see a lot of new faces
which is always great to see so I'm a
you could say local practicing
philosopher I used to teach in
universities and although I still do a
little bit of teaching on the side I'm
primarily in what you could call private
practice and so if you're interested in
I can tell you more about that later on
but I still do a lot of this sort of
intellectual work and I was really happy
to partner with the Frank Weinberg
library because this series focuses on
philosophers and it looks at Adam like I
said in the middle of history in their
historical context and what formed them
so at Thomas Hobbes there's probably
nothing more important than the English
Civil War which was a very you know
interesting set of events very dramatic
King loses his head you have one of the
first totalitarian societies at least in
the West arising-under Cromwell's
Protectorate Hobbes is not not at the
middle of it he's not an agent so to
speak but he's he's reflecting on what's
going on and it's part of a number of
other events that go all the way back to
the Protestant Reformation so we'll talk
about some of the background of that
before I go on if there's any questions
at any point or you want to make a
comment I'm perfectly happy to go
off-topic or you know talk about things
I can always bring it back to topic so
what I had in mind was to first talk
about you know Hobbes Europe and Britain
a little bit give you kind of the lay of
the land not just not in terms of maps
but in terms of great developments that
had taken place that were reforming him
not just him but everybody else the
things that everybody was talking about
the things that people were in many
cases obsessed with obsessed enough to
kill each other over and then we'll look
at Hobbes himself and how his long you
know over 90 years long life fits into
this and then we'll start focusing in on
some of his his key ideas I want to talk
about that in sort of two stages the
first stage I want to talk about his
bigger overall project what was he
really about what was what was the point
the things that he was writing at least
the ones that weren't just polemical
where he got in fights with people
because we'll talk about that as well he
spent a lot of ink getting and very
fruitless fights with with some people
but he he also contributed some really
earth-shaking really as I said it
without any hyperbole at all ideas to to
modern Europe things that affect us even
today
he's extremely relevant even in the
present time he does suffer a little bit
there's a bit of a digression and I'll
come back to this later he does suffer a
little bit by having written in 17th
century English which means that as
opposed to say 17th century French
people who can be translated into you
know 21st century English were stuck
with him with his you know weird
spelling and diction and so that makes a
little hard to read him right but once
we get past that terminological stuff
he's really a first-rate thinker he is
as important to modernity as a Rene
Descartes or Francis Bacon I would say
that he more than niccolò machiavelli
deserves the title of the father of
modern political thought for four
reasons we can talk about
so you might say wow you must be really
a fan of Hobbs and I'm not actually I
think that he sort of represents a kind
of danger the way that he thinks about
things that we want to be aware of but
he also sets the problems that we face
in in politics all the way down to the
present in a very helpful way so we'll
talk about some of those ideas so some
key aspects of that Hobbes Europe and
particularly the Britain that he lives
about two-thirds of his life in he
spends a good bit of time living outside
of Britain in part because of the tumult
going on there so I mentioned the
Reformation by the time that Hobbes is
coming on the scene the Reformation has
been going on for a while and you know
if you think about your church history
it's not one monolithic thing of you
know Protestants you know Martin Luther
getting the ball rolling and then
everybody being the Protestant team
versus the Catholic team instead think
of it as you've got the Catholic team
we're quite a few people are
undercutting each other you might say
that that some of them are trying to
jockey for team captain position and
keeping all sort of skullduggery around
that and then you get the Protestant
side where it it starts splitting off
into all these different groups so very
early on you have you know the
Lutheran's in Germany and then you have
the Anabaptists many of whom get wiped
out early on and then you have the
reformed you know the Calvinist
tradition
then there's spin-offs England was
particularly fertile in producing new
sects new new groupings some of whom
didn't actually fit in that well with
that and not fitting in well with the
spectrum meant that you didn't have a
safe place to live because you know it
wasn't just that you know if you were a
Protestant the Catholics might persecute
you
or you might persecute the Catholics if
you were the wrong kind of Protestant in
somebody else's territory
you would get persecuted and if you were
somebody like say a Quaker or until they
actually took over a Puritan well you
were going to get persecuted anywhere
you went just about except maybe the
Netherlands which is where you know some
of the the Congregationalists who would
later come here to the United States
forth through States settled for a short
time so there's all this religious
conflict that's ongoing and if you if
you look at who the key players are
especially in England you have there's
Catholics right but they you know except
for Mary's reign they're pushed out
Henry the eighth you know establishes
the Church of England Elizabeth is
really able to consolidate it there's
some attempts to try to intervene
actually a lot of attempts you know not
just on the part of the papacy and
Spanish but but other people as well
they're totally unsuccessful and so
England is you know essentially under
the Church of England which was fairly
conservative much like the Lutheran
Church was in Germany they didn't get
rid of a lot of things that that the
older Catholic Church had hit so that
actually provoked a lot of reaction from
more radical Protestants and so who
would those people be in this case up in
the north in Scotland you have the
Presbyterians right and they are sort of
lined up with with the churches in
Geneva you know the Geneva Bible is one
of the first English Bibles it antedates
the King James Bible which we'll talk
about shortly and so the you know
there's a whole different branch of the
Protestants up in Scotland who don't
really go along with the Anglican Church
then you have the Puritans and the
Puritans are Congregationalists they are
also Calvinists
at that time and that means that they're
a minority within England and they're
not being recognized the Puritans in
part because they say the English church
is still far too Catholic you know you
still have priests you're still putting
stuff on the altars you still have
stained glass you need to
get rid of all that stuff now if you say
things like that to people when they're
used to things being a certain way you
know they might not like it and in this
case they they didn't and quite often
the Anglican authorities came down
pretty hard on the the Puritans you also
have other groups you know the Baptist's
the Quakers you know the friends though
they're coming out of this this matrix
as well though the number of sects that
didn't survive the diggers the Levellers
is one that we read little blurbs about
generally the more violent the more
radical he were though the lower your
chances were of making it into the next
century as a group because it was a very
violent time so there's all this
religious ferment going on then there's
also wars between the nation's that are
kind of tied up with religion but also
tied up with the same old stuff of you
know who's going to be on top and you
know can we disrupt shipping you know
there a lot of like switching sides back
and forth that took place religion often
provided a great pretext for attacking
somebody or messing around with somebody
Spain and England had been at war for
quite a while
the Armada was just one little sort of
part of this long war going on between
them which would have some major
economic effects and it wasn't just
between nations there was also a lot of
conflict within nations so you know we
think of some countries like France as
being you know devoutly Catholic well
though there was a civil war that took
place within France and there was a you
know essentially not global but but
pan-european war that had taken place in
Germany that Rene Descartes would be a
soldier in you know the devastated half
of the German population at one one
point so there are these these struggles
within countries and and that affects
England so for example when when James
marries a Catholic or Charles the first
marries a Catholic print
says that sets off a lot of alarm bells
for people and they get very upset about
that sort of thing whereas you know
today we we get upset about all sorts of
other things you know if we found out
that somebody had the wrong sort of
political views and somebody that we
think is very important you know was
being friends with them or or you know
promoting them then we'd get upset about
that not so much about religious views
the way they did back then another thing
that was going on was a sort of
revolution in political order and what I
mean by this
was that the nation-state as we know it
as we think about it today was in
formation and some countries were really
on the leading edge of this others were
kind of sliding into something that
wouldn't work for them ultimately Poland
is a great example pulling the will end
up getting you know divided up in part
because they can't become a nation state
effectively in order to become a nation
state you not only need some sort of
ethnic identity but you need a
bureaucratic apparatus you need what the
French called the noblesse to the role
that is as opposed to the nobles who you
know had Rishta kradic titles the people
who could run the bureaucratic
administration something similar was
going on in England in both France and
in England there is also this
development of what we could call boil
absolutism this notion sometimes it's
tied in with what we call Divine Right
of Kings there was a lot of talk about
that at the time even if you stripped
away like the divine part of it there
was an argument being made that in order
for us to have peace and in order for
things to work properly somebody's got
to be in charge and that person has to
have absolute authority now what does
that mean that means that all the other
Nobles have to be under that person
somebody who you might think of who
really pulled this off well would be say
Willy the 14th right
so by taking all the nobles off their
land and bringing into the court where
they you know they could get in some
trouble right they they could you know
fool around and get into sexual daily
ensues and get to drunk and gamble away
but they couldn't like raise armies and
cause revolutions in England it was you
know Charles who is very strongly making
this this argument Charles was going to
get himself beheaded about royal
absolutism he's not the only one
James preceding him will actually write
philosophical tracts about this this
sort of stuff now what would be the
contrast to absolute monarchy some sort
of representative government not
representative like we have today like
with our electoral college and all of us
getting to vote I mean none of us would
have gotten to vote back then unless we
were from a noble family or somehow got
in somewhere if we remember the
Parliament and then we'd get a vote but
there was at least some notion that
there should be some people representing
the whole of the nation not just this
one guy or perhaps one woman in the case
of Elizabeth running the show and
telling everybody what to do and there
so there's a clash going on and this
ties in not just with the religious
things that are occurring
you know the Puritans favored a
representative government Anglicans
tended to favor the monarch achill
government it was also tied in with
economic interests you know we see the
rise of the bourgeoisie the you know the
people who are engaged in commerce who
are engaged in production in eventually
in industrial ways at first in you know
less organized ways and they generate
money and they would like to be
represented and they're not being well
represented by you know these Kings who
spend a lot of money to buy the way
these Kings their courts demand a lot of
money they also like to get involved in
very expensive Wars as opposed to much
cheaper Wars which you know the
commoners tend to be more in favor of so
you have this entire
of the commercial class or the
productive class you might say ongoing
and that's that's part of the picture
and I'll add one more big wrinkle to
this intellectually we're talking about
something else happening at the same
time not not just in terms of you know
changes of religious life and thinking
about one's relation to God and how
society ought to be organized there's
also the rise of modern science and a
new way of looking at things that is
being portrayed as sort of the opposite
of Aristotle knows everything now the
the way in which the moderns represented
Aristotle was usually pretty unfair to
Aristotle there are a few things on
which Aristotle is pretty boneheaded
there's a lot of things on which you
know he was sort of coming up with the
best theories he could at the time some
of which seem pretty plausible and then
there's some on which he's actually
still pretty good today there's Neil
orest Italians around who who still take
some of this stuff very seriously and
make good arguments the the moderns they
were often being confronted with people
who you might say we're sort of like
fundamentalists of Aristotle's work they
thought that the answers to every
question you just got to read
Aristotle's physics and find the right
passage and proof text it and now you're
done and if it conflicts with what you
actually observe too much that that's
too bad for what you observe right there
were a lot of people like that there's
like there's time servers in every
educational institution
throughout history right it's rare when
you get a genuine Aristotle or Socrates
or Rene Descartes rakamma table to be
your teacher much of the time
unfortunately you're stuck with people
who would rather you read the textbook
and shut up and get on with the work and
graduate right there's a good bit of
that you know fortunately I think
there's less of that today than there
was say around Hobbes time
but he's not the only guy going through
this you know Rene Descartes when he is
being educated in the Jesuit institution
of the flesh as a young man he hates
this sort of nonsense - and so Hobbes is
is actually going to be formed in a
Aristotelian or scholastic we call it
scholastic way of looking at things and
he'll he'll go away from that later
through embracing what he calls the
geometric method but that's going to
happen later on in his life for a long
time that he's just going along with
with that as the way we understand
things and he's got a very strong
reaction against that now all of these
things wind up getting tangled up
together the politics the religious
conflict the intellectual developments
they're all kind of playing off of each
other and so that's the backdrop leading
into Thomas Hobbes life and the lives of
all these other people that he's
interacting with the lives of the people
who are going to be engaging in a civil
war so let's talk about some of that and
how it comes about and why why it has to
do where Hobbes
gets into that and I've given you a
timeline which is you know is somewhat
helpful the Hobbes
stuff himself is on one side and then
other things are on the other side and
Hobbes had this great line about you
know he was born prematurely because his
mother was afraid because the Spanish
were going to invade the Spanish Armada
which turned out not to work out because
largely because the storms but also
because the English were able to cut
them off at certain points but really
largely because of you know things not
turning out the way they should
weather-wise was poised to invade
England they had a giant army in the
Netherlands which at that time was owned
by Spain and the reason why in part they
were doing as you know through a reclaim
English
for the Catholics but they're also tired
of the English messing around with them
in the Netherlands the English kept on
you know sending you know forces and you
know picking off you know Spanish ships
here and there so you know this is going
to settle things once and for all so
imagine that you know that this gigantic
fleet is on its way there's a gigantic
army across the way and you can didn't
see these guys so Hobbs his mother is
pregnant she she hasn't prematurely and
Hobbs says I was born a twin to fear and
that sort of set the tone for his
political theory and his life early on
his father is gone his father is a
clergyman gets in a fight with another
clergyman has to leave town fortunately
he's got an uncle who helps to raise him
because you know things are not
particularly good for single mothers at
the time Hobbs
you know studies in Oxford at Magdalene
Hall and they are you studying
scholastic philosophy that be that's the
stuff that they have at the time he
translates euripides medea this is
something that's going to be a feature
of his his life we don't really think
this much we don't think that much about
it but he did a lot of translation work
over the course of his life we've lost
his translation of the Medea but we have
some of the other ones now around this
time you notice that there's the
Gunpowder Plot you know Guy Fawkes Day
we remember Guy Fawkes was a pretty
radical Catholic they wanted to blow up
Parliament
this made cat that's really brought
Catholics into bad repute sort of a you
know a few bad apples throw the whole
bunch out so there were a lot more
stricter anti-catholic laws going into
play
you notice that around 1610 16 11 two
interesting things are happening so
Hobbs has become a tutor for this guy
William Cavendish William Cavendish the
younger William cabin
who's going to go to Parliament and
Hobbs will accompany him while he goes
to Parliament so Hobbs going to learn
about this sort of stuff and you know
you would buy being a tutor you became
part of the household you got to
participate in all these interesting
things that it opened up for you these
people were rich rich and very
well-connected soon after that he goes
you know William goes like any good kid
should to travel around Europe to finish
his education doesn't mean he's studying
books he's living in places and seeing
how people behave and meeting people
that's also very important part of it as
well
Hobbs goes with him now notice on the
world scene what's happening about the
same time they finally finish the
authorized King James version of the
Bible now why why is that you know a big
thing well before that the reformed
Protestants had their own Bible when
you're translating stuff you can really
steer it one way or the other depending
on what you're doing with the Greek and
Latin
well Greek and Hebrew texts in this case
although they're consulting the Vulgate
from time to time and you know these
these the Geneva Bible really
represented a reformed point of view it
did not represent the Anglican point of
view so they could quote scripture to
these Anglican Divine's and the Anglican
Divine's were kind of at a disadvantage
so what's the best thing to do
they don't get to use that Bible anymore
this is the authorized version and it
was translated by people who had in mind
the agenda of the Church of England
which is the agenda of the King of
England James King of England and
Scotland both combined the irony of it
there's a little bit of a digression is
that here in the United States we tend
to associate the King James Version with
what we could call low church
protestants right so where there's not a
lot of institutional structure very
conservative it's exactly those sort of
people that the Kings James Bible was
translated to marginalize to cutoff but
it got embraced by by them here with you
know in kind of an interesting twist so
now you notice that Cavendish becomes a
member of parliament Hobbs accompanies
him there eventually he winds up on the
outs because William Cavendish senior
dies of the plague something that you
could very well die of back then and the
wife and widow says well we don't need
you anymore
so Hobbs fortunately finds some some new
work he becomes a tutor to Gervase
Clifton travels to Paris with him and
doing all these sorts of things Hobbs is
notice he's getting close to forty years
old by this time he's developing
contacts he's seeing the world he's not
actually producing a lot of work at this
time a lot of what he's going to do is
much later in life as opposed to quite a
few of the other philosophers who are
showing great promise
early on meanwhile all of this is
happening things are getting worse and
worse in England the Parliament adopts
this petition of right they want to
constrain the powers of the English king
they want to no longer allow him to do
this to do like you know billet troops
on their their property to establish you
know certain kinds of taxes Parliament
is getting into a clash and what you've
got here are two parties that are not
going to back down Parliament wants
representative government the king wants
everyone else to shut up and do what he
tells them to do because he's the king
the Duke of Buckingham winds up getting
assassinated the Buckingham is a very
close friend of the King Charles opens
the parliament gets into a clash with
the parliament over taxes he wants to
start another war he wants money for it
and they won't do it so now he starts
this long period of ruling without
parliament
kind of similar to what happens
in you know our government when we talk
about gridlock when you know one
political party holds the executive
branch and the other political party
dominates the legislative branch you
know we've seen quite a lot of that over
the last you know several decades how do
you do that well you know we talked
today about executive orders and there's
a lot of debate usually both sides are
okay with executive orders when there
are sides in charge I mean they're
totally against it site is in charge
right that's similar to ruling without
parliament for an English king and you
notice that a lot of the stuff is is
about the same kind of issues who who
should be in charge who gets to decide
where the money goes
who gets decide how much money we're
going to draw what's the money going to
be used for all of these sorts of things
Charles keeps pushing and pushing and
pushing he appoints this guy loud to be
Archbishop of Canterbury that would be
sort of like today you know once you're
president you you pick somebody for some
important office like a Supreme Court
justice or Secretary of State or
something with real power and you push
in somebody who's like super hardcore
ideology on your side but also very
slick very very very good talker and the
parliamentarians they don't like that
you know so things are going back and
forth meanwhile Hobbes himself he's had
sort of a revolution of thought he came
across Euclid and Euclid of course we
know the elements of geometry he is one
of the classic geometrician 'he's part
of what's what's really key to early
modern philosophy is this notion that
philosophy and they don't just mean
philosophy in the sense that we study it
today in in philosophy departments but
philosophy in a very broad sense
including psychology including political
science including physics including the
study of the entire natural world should
all be modeled after
mathematical ways of doing things
mathematical of geometrical you begin
with with axioms maybe you get those
from observation or something like that
but you begin axioms and then you you
rigorously and deductively argue from
from those this is a very different
approach and that's what you see Hobbs
doing for instance in Leviathan he's
adopting a geometric method as far as he
understands it it's not completely clear
that the Hobbs always had the greatest
grasp although he was in a tutor in
mathematics but it's not always clear
that Hobbs had the greatest grasp on
exactly what was going on with this he
eventually he becomes tutor to another
William Cavendish young William
Cavendish he resumed his role in the
family returns to England he's going to
have a couple more trips he goes back to
France meets this guy Marin Mersenne who
if you don't know about him he's a
really interesting fellow he didn't
produce a lot of work himself but he was
sort of the connector of Paris at that
time he's the guy who makes rene
descartes scurry r-- he connects people
up together he's the guy who brings
everybody in nowadays we call this
networking right he is the master
networker and he's very generous about
he's like you know you're doing this
stuff with optics over here well that
guy over there he's also interested in
let me let me introduce it to him he's
doing this by letters he's doing this
with personal introductions very very
interesting hobbes meets all these these
big movers and shakers in in paris he
also visits florence and now things are
coming to a head by the six late 1630s
charles tries to force the Scots to use
the Anglican prayer book you know he
wants a unified Kingdom the Scots refuse
he raises an army and and that costs a
lot of money by 1640 Charles needs to in
order to keep keep going on with these
things needs to get some taxes passed so
there's the short Parliament which he
can't get along with and dismisses and
then things start to get out of hand and
the long what's called the Long
Parliament gets convened and by now the
parliamentarians have learned their
lesson about dealing with this king you
know don't let him be the only person to
to call the agenda and things things are
already out of hand but they start to
get more and more and more out of hand
and eventually they wind up in 1642 in
full civil war between the Royalists the
people who are supporting the king and
the parliamentarians and interestingly
you you know scholars have done this
this sort of work you know demographic
work they've looked at like well who who
went for who right so there's certain
areas like the north of England they
tended to be royalist other rural areas
those usually were Royalists the
Cathedral cities interestingly went
parliamentarian the commercial centres
parliamentarian as well and so you've
got a social clash as well as a
religious clash and a political clash
going on meanwhile Hobbes himself is is
you know continuing on in in Paris he
gets involved with Descartes and the
card is really one of the main people in
him and Galileo involved with the new
modern philosophy he contributes some
objections to Descartes meditations he
writes one of his early important works
a date-date today on the citizen the
work of political philosophy he doesn't
publish it quite yet he starts to
contribute to other things at the same
time while he was living in Paris the
Royalists who are starting to lose
they're heading to Paris as well Hobbes
has already got a lot of connections
with people of that persuasion and you
know he himself does believe in a strong
you know monarchic Oh
old government he hold up the
possibility could have a democracy
probably not going to work but you could
do it you could even have an aristocracy
that's probably not going to work
monarchy is really the way to go
so he's sympathetic to them but you know
more and more of them are coming in he's
getting involved in their circles
finally 1645
Charles is decisively defeated he's
taken prisoner he has a brief escape in
1647 and by 1649 he has tried and
executed and they switched to a
Commonwealth Oliver Cromwell is the
ruler of England and it's essentially
you know something like a totalitarian
state in the making I'm going in
meanwhile you notice that that Hobbes
becomes tutor to the younger Charles the
son of the King Prince of Wales and his
tutor in mathematics actually he begins
composing the work that he's best known
for Leviathan and rightly so Leviathan
is the most important thing that that
Hobbes ever wrote
Leviathan get gets finished in 1650 gets
published in 1651 it draws a lot of
receptive attention from some quarters
it also draws a lot of criticism
interestingly some of the criticism is
from the Royalists and some of the
Royalists are so upset with Hobbes that
they want to kill him so he actually
leaves Paris and goes back to England
any he you know affirms that he will
live under the republican government he
won't get involved in politics at all so
this is really you know almost like an
exile for him an exile within his own
country that kind of an interesting
thought right there he he also starts
getting involved in controversy with
people
some of these are sort of on point some
of these are less on point
there's a guy Bishop John bramble and he
he attacks Hobbs on a number of
different points you know the the
political theory Hobbs his view on you
know mechanism and materialism and you
know free will and necessity and stuff
like that Hobbs is perfectly willing to
spar with him and you know fight it out
in the press they write stuff back and
forth and back and forth
Hobbs also gets to get himself involved
in some controversies over mathematical
proofs of squaring the circle clearly
Hobbs is wrong on this stuff but he gets
involved with this guy Wallace and they
write track after track after track
after track that's not very important as
far as Hobbs scholarship goes right what
is really important as well via thon and
these other political treatises that
he's writing so he's got the date shiva
that he's written the translation of it
appears in 1651 he writes take corporeal
body sort of materialist mechanistic
view point on things and then finally
dae-ho moaning on on human being and
these are sort of a trilogy that could
be envisioned to be something like a new
text book this was something also at the
time that I should mention text books
you know we fight about text books now
right and we tend to fight about text
books here in the United States mainly
in terms of science and social studies
right or history you know who gets
represented in the histories and are we
going to teach theory of evolution are
we going to teach intelligent design
along with it you know those sorts of
things right the textbooks that these
guys have in mind are the textbooks that
will be used in the universities because
you know what we now understand it the K
through 12 education is not public at
that time for the most part there you
know you said
you can send your kid off or they go to
tutors what really mattered was
universities and whoever could sort of
control the philosophical textbooks
would determine the mindset of people
who are in there so there's scholastic
textbooks like Aristotle's physics is a
textbook well there might be
commentaries on it Rene Descartes when
he is writing his principles of
philosophy that's supposed to be a
textbook that University students would
use John Locke's essay winds up becoming
a textbook for people to use Hobbes is
writing things it could be textbooks all
sorts of people are doing this why is
that so important because if you control
the basic mindset and principles that
people are using you determine where all
the other studies are going to go
because remember what our universities
fundamentally about at this time it's
not about you know producing you know
people go to business school and get an
MBA that that's like stuff that happened
in the 20th century the late 20th
century the three traditional
professions that that people are being
prepared for in university theology law
medicine philosophy is an important part
of that I mean eventually they're going
to branch out into other things but
these are supposed to be preparing
people to engage in public life so by
providing the the textbook you in a way
set the agenda I hope this will be a
part of Hobbes as ideas later on you
notice that as things go on eventually
the monarchy is restored and notice
what's restored with the same guy who
Hobbs tutored so Hobbes now has a place
for life he can go to the court the King
used to call him his old bear apparently
Hobbes was in pretty good shape we're
talking about this a little bit before
one of the ways that Hobbes claimed that
he stayed in shape was by singing in his
room by himself so we're kind of
speculating I wonder what kind of songs
you know how loud he was singing
because you know in order to actually
get exercise from it maybe he was
dancing for those but Hobbs is now you
know sort of made it and he he does
publish a few other things he he
publishes some translations of Homer he
also publishes a an autobiography in
Latin Leviathan gets gets translated
into Latin that is a sign that it's
being recognized as centrally important
because if you really want to be taken
seriously at that time even all the way
up to the you know early 1800s you need
to be in Latin because that can be read
universally across Europe in way Hobbs
is going the opposite direction of
decart Descartes meditations are written
in Latin first Descartes write them in
Latin doesn't even translate them into
French himself as another guy do the
translation and says that good enough
and in some cases a little bit of
periphrastic it's not exactly what the
Latin text says and Hobbes is going the
other way Leviathan has made it because
it's been translated into Latin behemoth
is the companion piece to Leviathan you
know these are two legendary beasts in
the Bible in the book of Job right the
Leviathan and then the sea the behemoth
on land behemoth is a history of what
took place in England and how everything
went self how everything fell apart how
they the Commonwealth before not not
actually called the Commonwealth though
the monarchy how that broke down and get
replaced by by forces that in Hobbes's
view were more and more inimical to
public safety and to good politics
doesn't get published the reason why it
doesn't get published while Hobbes is is
still around is because the king suggest
to him that you shouldn't publish this
it does afterwards and it's a really
interesting piece very few people read
it but if you want to see how Hobbes's
theory in Leviathan gets translated into
you know some sort of real conditions
that's the book to read and you can see
similar dynamics of social disorder and
breakdown by factional ization happening
throughout history so that's a good
lead-in actually before before I talk
about Hobbes's ideas I've been talking
at you for a long time and nobody's
asked any questions which is very nice
but I'm sure you guys must have some
questions or comments I should take a
break yeah one of the things in my uh
number of things that impact culture the
material world the app and the drive for
religion and science to understand like
variables think of the grasses and its
impact on society going back to biblical
basis if you have any idea because what
I'm noticing is that the technology the
computer
yeah is impacting on the cultures a long
time security I to burn y'all dragons
yeah you have any comments throughout
history how the philosophy going to be
impacted by technology
clicked illogical advances all that
we're not splitting predicting the
impact of the wheel when the wheel
commit invented and how agriculture
ability produce surplus food victim etc
finger so I'll say two things right up
the bat one is that the introduction of
of Technology once it becomes pervasive
enough provides sort of imagery and
metaphors that can be used by fight
philosophers but also by other people to
every citizen in literature too right so
in the early modern period for example
with Hobbes you know he mentioned that
he has a materialist conception of
things right so he thinks everything is
material even got he thinks his material
which is kind of hard to explain but he
spends the last two books to look like
I'm basically trying to do that with it
with a exegesis of Scripture that nobody
buys you even have to climb now it's
also a mechanistic conception of nature
and of the human being so he gets very
detailed about this and he talks about
like when we're talking about our ideas
and how we get them he conceives of the
nerves as something like you know
pulleys and gears and I mean we know
that that's not the case but he's sort
of trying to work with the best
scientific conception he has at the time
of how this could be the case he sees
the animals as being just you know pure
machines we are machines
now where did that come from well it's
because they're actually developing
technology and machinery and people like
him can look at it day after day would
that have been possible say in the 1200s
probably not you know so there's things
like that the ways in which people
imagine things and then the other thing
is yeah you're right so the the adoption
of the wheel facilitating travel or you
know the developments with agriculture I
mean there's the first getting getting
together in groups I mean by the time
that we're talking about philosophy
we're talking about fairly developed
societies but there's agricultural
developments going on that are changing
the you know what's a profitable crop
and what's not a profitable crop the
other thing is to they're in contact
with a new world by now so new
foodstuffs are coming over and in you
know influencing things there's a vast
influx of wealth into Europe as well all
of that is possible because of
development of you know nautical
technology and being able to to just
move things that opens up new
possibilities for philosophers to do
things differently there's greater space
for thinking you could say and there's
when it comes to politics I guess in a
way there's more to fight over right the
more shear wealth that you're developing
there's more a fight over now the
computer thing is a really interesting
thing to bring up because the changes
that have happened just in our lifetime
are so fast compared to the rate of
social change say back in Thomas Hobbes
time right things took longer to get
implemented
I mean consider this with this iPhone
you know 10 years ago
this was considered almost you know
utopian revolutionary kind of stuff
and the iPhones that people had back
then didn't have anything close to the
capacity this is this one's like four
years old so it's out of date you know
but the ones that they had ten years ago
were much less powerful than this and if
you were to show this to somebody from
you know say 2000 they'd be like well
what the hell is this is a nice piece of
glass here I don't know what you've got
in your hand there's been so much you
know there's there's philosophers who
actually theorized about this in terms
of speed there's one who's got a great
phrase he's a he's dead unfortunately
ultimate card tackle genic unworldliness
he called it this feeling like we're not
we don't really know where the hell we
are anymore
because the world has changed so much in
just a few decades it's sped up so much
you know and one things I use the word
nation oh yeah and the time it's a
talking about they should then something
much different than it is today
cafes include territory yeah for
whatever reason we are not interested
just one more yeah that's a change
because of our mobility and we're able
to define where we come from
by seeing what's outside the territory
yeah and we have better methods to
elevator yeah yeah you don't James James
the sixth of Scotland who becomes James
the first of Scotland and England wants
to call himself James of Great Britain
and Parliament doesn't like that they
don't want it what to have it recognized
as being one nation and he makes a
geographical argument about this saying
look it's one island
you know obviously we're meant to be one
political community and they're like no
no no there's Scotland
there's England also there's Wales - but
you know by then they're they're
subjugated so yeah and you think about
France right it took a long time for
ants there's actually a great book by
Boyken Weber great historian who is
called peasants into Frenchman and sort
of tracing out the development of the
idea of a french nation
he says you really don't have much of
that until the 1800s you know I mean you
doing in Paris right because they're the
ones who control everything but you
don't in the back areas so I think yeah
I think you're right about that and the
development of means again I am app with
me now everywhere I go that can tell me
where I am on the map you know when we
have maps before like the road atlas you
had to actually have some idea where the
hell you were okay or it wasn't any good
for you you know are you still in
Wisconsin or if you crossed over into
Illinois what what highway are you on
you have to actually look for signs to
peel to tell where you are and now the
technology so my kids who are who've
grown up with this I don't think they
look at paper maps I don't think they
know how to you know I don't think
they're doing that in school I could I
couldn't tell they know how to use the
technology but they they don't really
you know they don't have the same
relationship with it that we do who grew
up with paper maps and for whom this is
sort of what we call a derivative
reality for them this is the reality you
know yeah so great question well let me
talk about some ahab's ideas and some of
these may you know be fascinating for
you and some of them may be repugnant
for you and you have some reactions
against them before I do that I said
that I wanted to talk about his general
project so his general project does tie
in with this historical development
Hobbs wants to have a his view totally
scientific explanation of everything
from where ideas come from
matter interacts to what God would be
and nobody pays any attention to that
part of his work anymore and especially
to you know political and ethical
matters within societies that we
actually live in so here's some of his
key ideas oh by the way why do you want
to have a completely scientific account
is it just for the sake of doing science
because you love science no it's very
practical because this is the only thing
that is going to allow us to live in
peace and to enjoy you know a life free
of fear a life where we can develop you
know through technology our potentials
and enjoy you know the fruits of our
labors if we don't have a completely
scientific account and we're relying on
something like Aristotle or you know
what's impurity and divine says or you
know whatever wild whim some king has
then we're really screwed you know we're
going to be relying it sort of like
garbage in garbage out for computers if
we start with bad data and bad theories
we're just going to mess things up so
he's hoping to provide the blueprint for
social harmony by providing the
scientific account now I gave you a
handout which is quite lengthy and I
don't expect anybody to look at it all
right now this is something I provide my
students with when I teach Hobbs and
it's about his his theory of human
conflict and he talks about human beings
as you know existing in Canada like we
can call it an abstract state of nature
who imagine that we don't have any any
governing body we don't we don't have
anyone setting the rules and you know
sort of like answer you know people that
survive or show they're on the island
imagine that there's no cameras anymore
or you know judges coming in and
everybody can do what they want to do
Hobbes says well people in those sort of
situations are going to kill each other
and we are the most dangerous animal why
because we don't just kill each other
over things like
who gets the meat or who gets to mate or
things like that
we have even better reasons to kill each
other does it go way beyond that so
there's what he calls competition right
you know we we're going to compete over
the same kinds of resources land access
to you know fertile areas where we can
farm our sheep or or you know maybe a
river that we like we might compete over
mates we might compete over you know
whatever and as a matter of fact if I do
well and I've got stuff and you don't
have it you're going to want to take it
from me this is a natural desire
according to Hobbes so if my farmland is
better than yours you know then you're
going to want to take my farmland and
the products now this leads to the
second reason for human conflict so
there's not only competition but I can
predict that they'll be competition so
that means that if I know that my land
is better than your land I know that
you're you sooner or later even though
you smile at me and you know you wave
hey neighbor
sooner or later you're going to try to
kill me so you can take my land so the
rational thing to do given that there's
no government or anything like that then
I kill you before you kill me I could
preemptively attack you now you of
course can also think well that guy sees
that you know my land isn't as good and
he's already thinking that I might
attack him so he's probably going to
attack me so I would attack him first
now you noticed that if things are just
sort of escalating right everybody is
now looking for an opportunity
the third thing Hobbes says that we will
get into conflict beyond all of that
over vanity he says for a trifle over a
smile or a lack of a smile over somebody
being laughed at we want to be valued by
the other people it's not just enough
that they keep their hands off of our
stuff we want them to feel a certain way
about us and we're willing to engage in
conflict with them
about that so this makes us really
really dangerous right because if you
know that your neighbor looks like that
you know your neighbors you manage to
equalize everyone's got the same amount
of grain and you come to some sort of
you know decision look you know you're
not going to cross over to my territory
because as soon as I see your coming I'm
going to kill you and I won't do that
with yours Hobbs says you can still
fight over over vanity over who's you
know sports team is better who's whose
house looks prettier or things like that
so this makes us incredibly dangerous
and this means that at any given time if
we're being rational unless there's
something to keep us in check we always
have to suspect everybody because you
know we would do the same this is Hobbes
reasoning now of course you know this is
coming out of a situation in which
people are in fact acting like that you
know civil wars are taking place people
are killing each other sometimes over
religion sometimes using religion as a
pretext sometimes you know just because
they like the other guys boots and
they're going to take them so there's a
lot of this going on Hobbes is writing
in a situation where this kind of makes
sense so that's one key idea I mentioned
the state of nature Hobbes Hobbes talks
about you know when you're lacking some
sort of stable government you're in a
what he calls the state of nature
there's a lot of discussion about just
how serious he is he about this to the
you know does he think that there really
is a state where there's no governance
whatsoever
my view is no that's not actually the
case I actually have a paper where I
distinguished five different states of
nature that Hobbes talks about what he's
really concerned with though is the
breakdown of social order he thinks that
you know like in a society like ours
imagine tomorrow that we have some kind
of natural disaster and somehow let's
just take mecklen right somehow Mack Wan
gets cut off from the rest of the world
I don't know how it happens maybe
some perfect earthquake that goes along
the city line it's something like that
and let's also assume since you're being
far-fetched here you know we can imagine
whatever we like every police person
dies all of the officers of the court
die there's some sort of virus that goes
at some some sort of occupational virus
who else would we have to take out of
the thing the firefighters we could
leave we could leave around the teachers
I suppose so long as they're not too
prescriptive right now you know they're
you know there's a couple shopping
centers so we've got food not a lot of
farming going out here in Mequon anymore
not like the old days right so it's not
really sustainable for all of us people
what would we do in the in the
supermarkets how would we behave okay
and what would that I mean we each going
yeah so we would get into conflict if I
see you being a particularly successful
looter maybe I don't even have to do all
the looting I just wait until you get
out of the store with like a whole bag
handling yeah bop you on the head and so
Hobbs thinks that this is our natural
condition now he's not embracing this
he's nothing this is a good thing the
goal is how do we get out of this and
this is where he proposes he's one of
the first explicit theorists of this he
proposes the social contract he says
we're reasonable creatures not only can
we use our reason to like predict when
can I get the drop on that guy or is
that guy try to kill me something like
that we can also use reason to see that
you know if we could actually get along
things would be a lot smoother we
wouldn't have to devote so much time and
the tension and anxiety to worrying
about what the other guy does if I do
manage to grow a crop I don't have to
worry about somebody else taking it away
from me wouldn't that be nice now that
can only work if I'm not the only person
willing to do it if I'm willing to do it
but you're not willing to do it but I'm
what we call these days of sucker
right and it doesn't make sense to be a
sucker so if I can get you to agree and
you can get me to agree and we all do
this together then we can start working
out some some ways to live together and
you know it's sort of like what goes on
in when people are roommates right who's
going to wash the dishes you know who's
going to clean the toilets you know
these sorts of things people work these
out over time and they often do so by
saying isn't it better for all of us if
we don't need to eat each other's food
that's been labeled in the common
refrigerator or if you mess up the
dishes do the dishes right and sometimes
there's like some guy who doesn't want
to do the dishes and then they all pile
in on him right well that's what Hobbes
says ought to happen you you probably
need somebody who's really powerful to
be able to do that and so you know these
laws of nature that he suggests they
tell us things like well we should you
know form you know communities and
appoint somebody to be in charge and
give that person enough power to punish
us if we if we step out of line but we
should also do stuff like nobody should
mess with anybody else just to mess with
them right
nobody should give offense to other
people if you know somebody's waving a
white flag don't shoot that guy that's
actually one of his rules he comes up
with a whole bunch of interesting rules
what he calls the laws of nature
now what's needed in this this is
another key idea I mentioned there's got
to be somebody in charge Hobbes calls
that person with sovereign and you know
we have sovereigns right we have a
president if we're working in a
corporation there's kind of a sovereign
the CEO some of them are kind of weak
some of them are very strong I suppose
in a school it would be the principal or
the superintendent or whoever right
somebody's ultimately in charge here's
what gets really interesting and here's
where a lot of people disagree with
Hobbes Hobbes says that the sovereign
must have unquestioned authority
the sovereign must be absolute because
if you diluted it anyway
sooner or later everybody's trying to go
back to the state of nature everybody's
trying to get their own little thing so
you know there shouldn't be any checks
on the power of the sovereign he or she
ought to be totally in charge if they
decide that they want to kill you
you have the opportunity to resist and
it's okay for you to do that just don't
expect it to work and quite frankly
you're actually a rabble andd wrong by
by doing that in Hobbes is view because
you're disrupting the social order the
sovereign look at the sovereign is like
well you know he's got this picture
right of a giant man composed of other
men and it's got both the mitre and the
sword and imagine the sovereign is like
looking down now that guy is causing
trouble what cut him in half you know
that's what it's doing Hobbes goes even
further with this and this is where we
you know we might have some problems
with this notion of absolute sovereignty
already Hobbes goes further not only
should the sovereign have what we
nowadays call complete monopoly of force
less here and sort of unquestioned
authority they should control the
intellectual life of the nation there
shouldn't be Hobbes
probably gets very specific about this
you know when it comes to the civil law
those guys who are like reading Cicero
and Aristotle get rid of them those
preachers who are preaching this and
that that goes against get rid of them
too if they tell them they have to shut
up first of all and burn those books and
if they won't stop you got to kill them
the sovereign this is where it starts to
become something like a totalitarian
Society there can only be one point of
view other people can have other points
of view so long as they don't conflict
with the point of view of the sovereign
and that point of view includes the
sovereign is always right even when even
when you know they're going against
things the only thing
that can really be bad on the part of a
sovereign is not keeping the peace and
Hobbes himself is so afraid of what
happens in civil war he's you know he's
very thoughtful about this
it's matches that people fight with each
other the entire moral fabric of the
society gets torn apart words stop
meaning what they used to mean like
justice or fidelity you know when you
have a real civil war that's part of the
damage that gets done you know
especially if it goes on for years and
years and years and Hobbes is very
attuned to that so we might say that his
diagnosis of these kind of situations is
dead-on and then perhaps disagree with
his remedy for them this is absolute
sovereignty backed by you know complete
control over ideas but notice I said
that his ideas are still very timely
this is some of the things that people
advocate today you know the national
security state has to be unchecked
otherwise we're not safe there's some
ideas that are just too dangerous we
have to squash them they can't be in the
public marketplace of ideas those who
who say those sorts of things we've got
to find some ways to silence them and
you know this is not exactly I mean for
Hobbes would be the sovereign doing that
you know we often just make it somebody
ought to do something the people are
saying stuff like this and they're not
just saying it of course here it gets
set in all places all over the world you
know when we see failed States in
different parts of the world where civil
war is taking place and everybody's
fighting ants everybody that's that's a
Hobbesian situation and if we have a
warlord who comes to the fore and
manages to impose power and people are
saying well better that than then
discord like say in Syria with Assad
better to have him in place than to have
things breaking down or Saddam Hussein
people were saying that about him
horrific dictator who is doing terrible
things to his own people but people were
saying well it's better than everybody
being at everybody's throats so those
are Hobbesian situations too he helps us
understand what's what's going on so
that's kind of a good place to close
this and then we'll take any discussion
or questions I throw a lot of ideas at
you yeah religion into all this oh so
that's so there's we can talk about it
like in Hobbes's actual case right
Hobbes is devoted to the Church of
England because that's what the English
have and all those other preachers
basically ought to be silenced or
brought in he's sort of more absolutist
than the Anglican so the Anglicans are
usually a lot you know they're more lat
they're more lacks in that way they're
like so long as you're not preaching
revolution it you know it's pretty okay
when you start doing that now you're
really a problem so long as of course
you're not Catholic too
Hobbs lays down you know he's got
discussions in the same thing where he's
talking about the civil law about what
preachers ought to be able to say and
the the entire second half of Leviathan
is devoted to his theology which nobody
buys nobody at the time bought and he's
got all these biblical passages that
he's using to like back up his his views
those are in books 3 and 4 of Leviathan
which very few people read I've read
them really interesting stuff
I can't imagine ever trying to teach
them to students so now could you do
without religion Hobbes thinks yeah you
could but so long as religions on the
scene there has to be one religion that
that dominates and any other point of
view insofar as it conflicts with that
has to be silenced because otherwise
yeah yeah the sovereign gets I mean if
the sovereign decided tomorrow
we're all going to become Buddhists
sovereign decides so this actually goes
to the issue of well why did the
Royalists why didn't they like Hobbes
because the implications of Hobbes point
of view
isn't that the Stuart dynasty is the
legitimate dynasty whoever happens to be
in power they're the legitimate dynasty
you know so long as they can keep the
peace
it's okay so Divine Right of Kings not
not needed anymore you know it's a very
modern way of looking at things
whoever can keep whoever can enforce the
social contract and keep peace and order
in a very effective way deserves to be
in power and they ought to be backed up
in whatever way possible well you know a
fairly corrupt Guinness feeling like
like you know that of Charles spending
money and a left and right on all terms
of things that's not you know they could
read be through the lines and see that
Hobbes is really not their ally you know
separation is very clean separation
called secular religious world yeah was
not as the fine as it is in grown-up
words yeah here in the United States who
was sweet government still supports the
I think it's a Lutheran Church yeah but
somebody but only go and I'm right I
mean even have they even have like that
so that the concept of separation is one
of we grew up with the act of faith
secular world McCarthy what is also
striking the Thompsons
that if things are left a wound you get
the sword miss me idea physically of
entropy
yeah sure links will move a disorder
from order so you have to spend energy
to keep order which the physics
standpoint it's true yeah and he does
see it as essentially physics like
building up from the bottom through the
human body and our minds vision the
aerial parts of my impression is
involves the cart Darwin was a very
religious man who refused to publish his
book but he's worried about what the
church would say about that I beg God
kind of thing if I was much lady was a
very an observer of natural world
in the limitation of evolution yeah and
in nationhood as I think was defined in
today's turn because of technology
involves other things it also defines
area as well as the culture
at least need the money questions okay
that's a lot yeah I mean so religion
could act as a unifying force right but
even when it was it could also act as a
thing that you could use
opportunistically so even like in
Catholic countries where there's this
sort of veneer of hey we're all on the
same page not like those Protestants
over there there is a lot of this you
know competing and jockeying for like
who would be in charge there's you know
like a big big issue was um you know is
the French Church independent of theirs
can the French church kind of decide its
own its own stuff as opposed to the
larger church
we call this Gallican ism and and what
you see is yes so you talked about you
know Hobbes thought that there was the
physics underlay everything and then you
get you know animal motion and then you
get you know Minds like ours and if you
if you could understand all this stuff
you would see why people do things the
way they do what their reasoning
processes are and how to modify them so
you talk about like how do you keep
things from breaking down into entropy
you need some very strong structures to
keep things in place and you here's
where the religion part comes in and
also you know other things you don't
once you've got a structure in place you
do not want people monkeying around the
bond structures making tweaks here and
there unless they're the person who's
authorized to do so right or a deputy of
that person because as soon as they
start doing that if like you can break
off a part of the mechanism and now that
can become independent over here and you
start getting the breakdown with entropy
hobbs does really think that when things
get terrible we really are in a state of
war of all against all
that's kind of a limit condition and
things have to go a long way to reach
that but he thinks that we can see that
happen in you know like saying a couple
decades of social conflict yeah so let's
return to religion he thinks it's the
strength of the structure is that
correct so if you would not really put
any credence into the the ten
commandments and thou shalt not kill and
these things being you know explained
you know by by the church to the people
the people accepting them at living by
yako it as opposed to you know we have
armies behind us well I mean if you look
at his laws of nature that were supposed
to be any any reasonable being should be
able to derive these as so the norms
that we would we would live in provided
we have somebody to keep the peace
a lot of the Decalogue is in there you
know respect for property
thou shalt not steal you know murder all
right even thou shalt not bear false
witness you know know the prohibition
against lying misrepresenting things I
mean I think Hobbes thinks that and
there's a lot of other thinkers who
think this the Decalogue could be I mean
even Thomas Aquinas obviously Decalogue
could be understood in terms of the
natural law in terms of how we ought to
how reasonable beings if they're going
to live together wat to comport
themselves towards each other
it gets more dicey when you get to like
the early parts like you know why do you
have to honor your mother and father
everything interestingly the ancients
when they're interpreting that they
tended to put that on the side of the
divine the precepts that had to do with
the divine because parents were kind of
semi-divine I don't think anybody in our
time probably thinks that all right and
so where did that drop out of the the
picture probably in modernity but you
know
having you know not taking Lord's name
in vain
Hobbs doesn't really worry so much about
things like that except insofar as it
could offend somebody so I guess he
would say look if everybody if the
sovereign likes the Decalogue you're
stuck with the Decalogue you know if the
sovereign likes something else you're
stuck with that you know which is
interesting because then what do you do
if you've got a sovereign and they die
and now the succession takes place and
let's say their kid is a total atheist
yeah what do you do you know it kind of
stuck with them that's one of the
problematic parts of his theory yeah
yeah
the Jim a question there okay
are there any other questions or
comments or
thank you when you're welcome to remain
oh great yeah I'm always happy to see
people I mean ideally now you all go and
read the liability I can't enforce it
possible for the land is immeasurable
structures very welcoming it doesn't
happen interaction petals yeah
you